- [Instructor] The function h is defined
over the real numbers.
This table gives a few values of h,
so they give us for different x values,
What is the value of h of x?
What is a reasonable estimate
for the limit of h of
x as x approaches one?
So with the table we
can estimate the limit.
We won't know 100% for sure,
but it's a good way to estimate a limit.
And so what they have here
is these first three entries
show what's happening as we approach
x equals one from the left,
from values less than x equals one.
So we can see, well what is
h of x for those x values
as we get closer and
closer to x equals one?
And we see, let's see
what when we're at 0.9,
it's 0.003, it's 3/1000.
Then we get even closer to one,
then the value of our
function is negative 4/100.
Then when we get even closer to one,
the value of h is 5/10.
So we have this oscillation in sine
and it seems like the absolute value's
getting larger and larger.
Now if we approach from the right,
we approach x equals one
from values larger than one,
so here's we're
approaching from the right.
At 1.1 we're at 3/1000.
At 1.01, we are at negative 4/100.
At 1.001 or one and 1/1000,
we are at 5/10.
So this is interesting.
When you have this oscillation of sine,
you say, "Well maybe we
might be approaching zero."
You know, maybe something
is getting closer and closer
and closer and closer to zero.
Maybe something like that is happening.
But what's troubling here,
the reason why I would say
that it's not reasonable,
it's reasonable to think
that the limit doesn't exist,
is here as we're getting
closer and closer,
here as we're getting closer and closer,
we're getting for the oscillations
are getting more and more significant.
So actually think of it this way.
As we're getting from the left,
as we're getting closer and closer,
the oscillations are
getting more significant.
And as we're going from the right
as we get closer and closer,
the oscillations are
getting more significant.
Now it looks like there's a
little bit of symmetry here.
Let me see if I can draw
symmetry reasonably well.
It looks like something
like this is happening.
But this is implying as we get,
as we go to 0.9999, then
we're going to oscillate again
and we're going to get even
further away from zero.
And so we're oscillating around zero,
but where the oscillations are
swinging wilder and wilder.
So we're definitely not approaching zero.
We're not getting closer because
the absolute value of these
aren't getting closer and closer to zero.
So I would say that the
limit doesn't exist.
So a takeaway here is when
things start to oscillate,
you're probably already say,
"Okay something fishy is going on."
But that doesn't mean that
the limit doesn't always,
it doesn't mean that the limit
necessarily doesn't exist
just because of the oscillation.
But if it's oscillating around a value
and as it's getting closer and closer
the oscillations are swinging wilder,
further and further away from that value,
then you have to worry.
And that then the limit
probably does not exist.
Let's do another example.
The function h is defined
over the real numbers.
This table gives a few values of h,
so it's a similar situation.
What is a reasonable
estimate for the limit
as x approaches three of h of x.
So let's see as x approaches
three from the left,
as x approaches three from the left,
it looks like, let's see 2.9,
we're at 2/10.
But at 2.99 we go to negative 2/100.
Then a 2.999, we get to positive 2/1000.
So even though it's oscillating,
magnitude-wise, we're getting
closer and closer to zero.
So this is an oscillation that you know,
it might look like this.
We're oscillating in sine,
but it looks like we're
getting closer and closer
and closer to zero here.
So this looks like we might be,
looks like our function
might be approaching zero,
as x approaches three from the left.
Now let's think about from the right.
Well from the right, we
see something similar here.
3.1, we're at negative 2/10.
3.01, positive 2/100.
3.001, we're even closer
to three, negative 2/1000.
And so it looks like we
are definitely oscillating,
but the oscillations are
getting less and less wild.
Their absolute values are
getting smaller and smaller,
so it actually seems reasonable,
we're oscillating around zero.
And with every swing as
we get closer and closer
to x equals three,
the oscillations are
getting smaller and smaller.
So once again, we don't know for sure.
We can't prove it mathematically.
But from this table it
is reasonable to estimate
that the limit here is zero.
Now these other choices are,
I would call them distractors.
This one down here is interesting
because the function is actually defined
at x equals three and it equals four.
But this might be a situation
where the limit is approached,
we're getting closer and closer,
but the function is
defined up here at four.
And this reinforces this idea that look,
the limit can approach a
value that is different
from the value that the
function is defined.
That's actually one of
the points of limits,
is to study what is a function approach
even when the function might
be defined at a different value
or even when the function
isn't defined at that value,
what is it approaching as
x approaches that value?
Now as I said, for this
situation it's not,
it's reasonable to think
that the limit exists.
I don't have any good
information to think otherwise.
We don't know 100% sure.
they put the three here,
but we're thinking about
what is h approaching
as x approaches three?
Now there's no information
here that would imply
that h is approaching three.
And at 0.22,
they're just playing with
the digits right over here.
But this is getting further from zero
than what seems like what
we're trying to approach,
so I'd rule that one out as well.
But the big takeaway here is
if you start to see, especially
on a table or anything
that as you get closer
and closer to a value
that the function is oscillating
that should kind of put your
spider senses on notice.
But that doesn't necessarily mean
that the limit doesn't exist.
If the swings are
getting wilder and wilder
as we approach the value that
we're oscillating around,
then the limit probably doesn't exist.
But if the swings, the oscillations,
are getting smaller in magnitude
as we approach the thing that
we're oscillating around,
in this case zero,
then is actually is reasonable to think
that the thing that
we're oscillating around
actually is the limit.